foreign
[Applause]
from Oxford to London and it was one of
those days that looked like it might
rain it might not so we made a plan on
the train I said okay if it's raining
we're going to go to the museum and if
it's not raining we're going to the zoo
and he said okay
so we got to marlabin station in central
London we walked out and
he said you know Dad I don't want to go
to the zoo or the museum I said what do
you want to do I said let's just walk
around
you sure yeah okay we just walked around
so at every intersection he said let's
go this way is it okay and so he just
led the way through London that day we
walked around for eight hours so
at one point he was jumping around park
benches and met these kids from Croatia
where they got into a little tickling
match and another time in like a little
Alleyway he saw this huge cardboard box
that was like almost as big as he is and
he got into this cardboard box and wore
it like a turtle shell so he walked
around London in a cardboard box for
like an hour and everybody would do
double takes looking at him and he felt
so cool in the cardboard box and then at
some point we found ourselves right in
front of the West End musical Wicked and
the show was about to begin in 10
minutes and I said do you have any
tickets what are the best tickets you
have they had eight throw Center tickets
they had two left so we're like yeah
let's do it let's go see Wicked so he
left his cardboard box there we went in
and saw Wicked and he at one point he
whispered to me he said Dad
okay and later I look over and he's
holding her hand he held her hand
through the old hands and so
was over we go home and I tuck him into
bed that night
and I said did you have a good day and
he said I had a great day and I said all
right so what was your favorite thing
today and he thinks for a bit and then
he said
cardboard box
and I was just like I marveled at that I
was just thinking later like
if I would have planned and said no
we're going to the museum come on it's
an important museum for you to know then
he wouldn't have had this
unoptimized experience and stumbled into
the cardboard box and so of course you
know I think about life and I think
about like
that day as a metaphor
for how we tend to make plans because
plans seem to be the the tool we use to
make the most of our time but that
doesn't always make sense does it
because like as you go through life you
keep getting new information moment to
moment
that helps you make the the best
decision for that moment not what you
thought would be the best decision
earlier when you made a plan which was a
prediction
so I think about like for example this
stupid house I'm in right now
so this is my stupid house everybody I
don't like this house
but here I am I would never guess based
on your assortment of matching plate
right how much energy I've clearly put
into this house and making it perfect
with all of its Decor
there's nothing on the wall no furniture
yeah except for some mice yeah
legitimately yeah I have three pet mice
we were going to bring them out that'd
be distracting
I thought about getting rid of this
house and getting a house that was more
suited for me
and I actually put an offer on a place
and it was a really nice place it was at
the end of Clyde key Wharf who's out
there like in the water and oh man it
was nice and so it was like the night
before my offer was accepted and it was
a night before I was gonna put down the
deposit it was going to be mine
I fell asleep that night thinking
like At first thought I was thinking I'm
gonna be so happy tomorrow and then I
thought
wait I'm already happy what am I gonna
be more happy tomorrow no I'm already
happy
it's like well then why am I doing this
why am I spending a bunch of money if
I'm already happy so I yanked it so I
didn't buy it and here I am in this
stupid house because it has no obstacles
like it's warm it's quiet
it's not suited to me perfectly
but that's okay like it doesn't get in
my way
and then from there I think how many
other things in our life
are we okay to just not optimize right
depends where you draw the line right
your romantic relationship your job your
family
oh but nobody has the perfect family of
their wishes
our location where you live our diet
like you have to kind of decide
what's worth optimizing that we don't
need to optimize everything it's okay to
have some things be good enough and so
I'm so glad you brought up the Paradox
of Choice by Barry Schwartz I really
[__] internalized that book it's a
great book the ending of that where he
says like okay I've been describing the
problem so what's a recommendation and
he says satisficing there's maximizing
and there's satisfies and I had no idea
you're gonna bring this up this is great
yeah yeah maximizers
have been found to feel worse about the
decisions they make they look into every
possible option they try to make the
best possible choice
but studies show that they feel worse
about the choice they make whereas
satisficers
may not make the absolute best possible
choice but they feel much better about
the choices they make so
yeah I think a lot of who I am
is because of satisficing and if I seem
like I make weird decisions in life
for example like not even continuing to
pursue making money it's because I'm
satisficing like I really took that
lesson to heart and have shaped my life
around it just for definition terms
right because people might think
optimizing is trying to eke out the
every last iota of improvement right but
I think what we're really talking about
is wait sorry to interrupt you know like
if you were to hear Paul McCartney go
Hey Jude you'd be like whoa just to hear
him sing two notes yeah to hear you go
optimizing
like whoa
That's a classic
sorry and if that is my legacy so be it
optimizing optimizing I think what we're
talking about is
where to focus your finite energy on
improving versus leaving things as they
are right in a sense right because I
think optimizing when I think of
optimizing optimizing is leading to
Optimal what does that even mean maybe
it's open-ended so it just continues
forever but
it's a helpful word I'm just curious how
you currently think about
where to focus your energy on improving
internal externally
versus leaving things be and this is a
conversation that's near and dear to me
one of my most effective friends
basically has said I'm paraphrasing but
he's like yeah I optimize for like one
or two things and everything else is
good enough like I just yeah I just have
to get it to good enough nice that's it
and he's
incredibly effective in life and he's
also a very happy guy
in general hard to know how much of that
is out of the box versus due to the
decisions and the way he views the world
but seems to contribute yeah so how do
you think about then
where you might maximize versus where
you satisfy or is it because I know it's
not good enough
across the board I find that hard to
believe
hmm
what do I maximize I'm not sure
or maybe maximizes to polarizing a word
no you know what I think it is yeah if
it's really fun okay if you think it's
just actually really fun to like maybe
some people set up their let's just say
they get into bread making and they're
just like I want to say it's like the
best bread making they're just having
fun with it then great they can maximize
you know people who get really into High
Fidelity audio Yeah and they nerd out
and they know it's stupid
usually yeah and they're just like I
don't care I want this thing with the
gold plated you know cable connector
right
and I think if you have fun optimizing
um then it's worth it if maximizing that
is if the process is fun to you
I think that should be the barometer but
I think that saying enough good enough
is a superpower